[Music]
the views and opinions expressed on this
program are those of the guests
appearing on the program and do not
necessarily reflect the views and
opinions of eight news now or next our
media group
i do believe that it is time uh for
nevada to actually kick off the
nominating process
tonight on politics now big news for
nevada the boost to our chances of being
the first state to nominate a president
in 2024 plus
morale has been super low
violence at schools the competing plans
from the administration and teachers at
ccsd on what to do about it plus racist
slides at an event with republican
politicians in attendance the reaction
and what they have to say about it after
the fact
[Music]
from eight news now
this is politics now
thank you for joining us on politics now
i'm john langler a huge step this week
towards nevada becoming the first state
to nominate a president in 2024 the
democratic national committee says iowa
and new hampshire are not guaranteed to
be the first states in the process and
that opens the door for nevada new rules
seem to favor our state as well
we spoke with artie blanco about it
she's on the dnc committee that's making
these decisions
what is your pitch what is the nevada
dnc's pitch to
the rest of the dnc of why nevada should
be first
well i think nevada's diverse population
and geogra geography represents the rest
of the country
our growing state is still small and
accessible enough to provide an early
test for all candidates to the white
house by allowing them to talk directly
to voters
and nevada's issues
are what's really shaping this country's
future
and big issues from climate change to
public lands um to tourism
um
and and to growth we won't be told about
the summer until we find out what kind
of
presentation what kind of pitch is being
put together now and how what are the
next steps down the line
sure and
you know the next steps are for states
to submit a letter of intent uh there's
a coalition of us from uh democratic
party leaders to our elected leadership
in the state
and
and other leaders within the state that
we are working together as a coalition
uh to make this happen
um and and here's the thing about the
presentation for nevada this isn't our
first rodeo we've actually did a similar
case in 2006
uh or 2005 and 2006 um when nevada was
first brought into the pre-window
um when leaders of the democratic party
realized that we needed to have more
diverse voices in selecting who the
future president would actually be
uh in their nominating process and so
nevada has done this we've been there
we had from labor leaders um
to come you know uh diverse community
leaders um as well as our elected
officials uh really making that pitch to
why nevada we've got the experience to
do this uh we're battleground we're
battle tested we test presidential
candidates on developing a winning
coalition to see if they can win um in a
general election which nevada is a
battleground state and will continue to
be
is the sort of lingering split within
the democratic party in nevada maybe a
deterrent if if you're on a national
level when you see what's happening
within the democrats in in nevada might
that be a reason to
not go with nevada first just because of
this sort of riff that's kind of
lingering around
we're all together on this we are all in
on this from our democratic party to our
democratic leadership to to everyday
democrats in nevada nevada democrats
we're together and we're all in this is
a fight we're doing together that we're
going to go for
a senior republican national committee
official confirms the politics now iowa
and new hampshire will go first on the
republican side of the aisle that means
nevada will be third or fourth
here in las vegas a 16 year old high
school student charged with beating up
and sexually assaulting a teacher set
off a firestorm of reaction this week
jonathan martinez-garcia is being
charged as an adult he's a junior at el
dorado high school a metro police report
obtained by the eight news now i-team
claims martinez garcia strangled the
teacher with a computer cord and cut her
with scissors
before his next court hearing martinez
garcia will be evaluated by at least two
doctors to decide his competency
that case was the latest in a string of
violent incidents at local schools
superintendent dr jesus jarrah and
teachers separately pitched plans to
deal with it this week dr jarrah's
proposal gives teachers a panic button
with bluetooth connectivity in the
classroom it asks police police agencies
to increase their presence at schools
and upgrade security cameras our
victoria saha asked why the
superintendent waited so long
why did it take for a teacher to be
brutally attacked to
take such swift actions such as a panic
button and increase in police presence
for the rest of the year i'm going to do
what i need to do to protect
our educators and
our students and i'm taking the actions
now
dr jarrah also says every school will
have an assembly coming up to tell
students that violent acts on teachers
and staff will lead to immediate
expulsion proceedings
so in response this week parents the
teachers union and trustees danielle
ford and linda cavazos held their own
protest at headquarters making separate
demands they want those classroom
buttons in the phones and the cameras
but they also want a district-wide
policy on what to do if there's a fight
in the classroom they also want a
conflict resolution program put in place
and taught to students and staff
i can tell you that every year for the
last few years we've always felt like
we're scraping at the bottom of the
barrel morale has been super low
if we couldn't get any lower last week
was it i'm
really upset by some of the actions that
are not being taken and some of the
approaches that are being taken with
ccocc that i don't know are going to
really make a dent in the major problems
that we have
the teachers say these are short-term
solutions from administrators they fear
a mass exodus of teachers and staff if
long-term changes are not made
some republicans were in the hot seat
this week after racist comments were
made at an event that they intended the
i-team's vanessa murphy spoke with
people involved in that event and she
has the story
the naacp is responding after racist
comments were made at an event last
weekend it's a story the 8 news now
i-team first reported tuesday night in
attendance sunday several nevada
republicans running for office it was
dubbed as a mass ccw event meaning
training to carry concealed weapons we
want to warn you the following clips are
offensive
firearm safety is no jump always wear a
wife peter on the range
and always make sure there are no
minorities in your backdrop
all your shoots are done right side up
always leave the chicken grease off your
fingers before shooting
always make sure there's a white person
around so you have someone to blame for
everything that goes wrong
and always aim for small children to
ensure you actually hit another gang
member
the head of the naacp las vegas chapter
says it's sad and disappointing to see
candidates condoning this type of
rhetoric and how can you say you will
fairly represent all people and allow
racist rhetoric against others we
reached out to north las vegas mayor
john lee who's seen in video in the
front row he hasn't provided a response
lee is running for governor assemblyman
tom roberts who's running for clark
county sheriff says he spoke at the
event but was not present during that
portion he also says he condemns the
language used sherelle mendenhall who's
running for senate says she gave a quick
speech and then left and as she was
leaving she says she heard the
instructor say this is an r-rated class
and i bust on everyone equally and noah
malgieri who's running for congress sent
us a lengthy statement saying he never
attended the instructor's class but he
doesn't believe he's racist you can find
more on this story and full statements
from the candidates the instructor and
the library district since the event was
held at a library at eight newsnow dot
com
and that was vanessa murphy reporting
the promotional literature for the event
also featured gubernatorial candidate
joey gilbert and treasurer candidate las
vegas city councilman michelle fiore
both said they did not actually attend
the event to the governor's race current
republican front-runner joe lombardo the
sheriff of clark county might be feeling
some heat from a new opponent a lombardo
supporting pac has a new add out against
john lee
john lee he's not who he claims to be
lee's actually a 25-year liberal
democrat
so the ad attacks the north las vegas
mayor john lee as you heard there a fake
conservative you're looking at an ad
here now lee of course was registered as
a democrat for years he recently
switched this ad was paid for by better
nevada pac that supports sheriff
lombardo
new polling does show though there might
be some cause for concern for the
sheriff the poll shows head-to-head
match-ups of republicans and current
democratic governor steve sisilak this
was done by the reno gazette journal and
suffolk university the polls show both
lombardo and lee ahead of sisilak in
head-to-head matchups he was tied with
dean heller beating joey gilbert
governor sisalak was at or below 40 in
all of the matchups on the senate side
both republicans adam laxalt and sam
brown had a thin lead on incumbent
democrat catherine cortez masto all the
races are within the margin of error in
this poll
while laxalt is ahead in that poll you
just saw senator cortez masto is way
ahead in fundraising in the first
quarter of this year she has raised 4.4
million dollars laxalt raised only 1.6
million dollars sam brown has not
released his numbers just yet
all right moving north las vegas forward
we've got to diversify our economy
next on politics now we speak with one
of the candidates for mayor pat spearman
about neglected neighborhoods and what
the city's economy really needs
plus building more affordable housing
the governor's plan to give people a
place to live that they can pay for
on politics now
seriously before you buy anything ever
welcome back to politics now
we've been hearing it from you many of
you have been complaining about the
hikes in rent in southern nevada and the
challenge to find an affordable place to
live state and federal leaders say help
is on the way and a program called home
means nevada is a start the 8 news now
i-team's vanessa murphy is back with
that story
building right up on blue diamond is the
same building these are apartments being
built for seniors with a lower income
congresswoman susie lee says the average
unit here on fort apache near blue
diamond will cost about 800 dollars
that's far below the average rent in the
las vegas area of about 14.50 i think
all of us who serve the public
can remember many times during this past
year having seniors and low-income
families call us complaining about
seeing their rents increase and not
knowing what they were going to do yeah
that's like a movie room congresswoman
lee governor steve siselek and other
federal and state leaders visited the
construction site to reveal more about
home means nevada the governor saying
500 million dollars for the program is
the largest housing investment in the
state's history affordable apartments
like this are being built and rescue
money to help people stay in their homes
is available getting just one more
person just one more person into a home
or keeping one more family in their home
is what this is all about he points to a
shortage of 84 thousand affordable units
for nevadans the more than 400 000
people moving here over the last decade
and the median price for a home of more
than 450 thousand dollars housing is an
immensely complex issue vanessa murphy
live local now
so the state is looking for business and
community partners to get affordable
housing projects going all across the
state pre-applications are being
accepted right now we have a link to
that and a link for renters and
homeowners that need help at
eightnewsnow.com
democratic assemblywoman pat spearman
she's a lot of things she's a retired
military policewoman a pastor a musician
and a doctor has a doctorate in business
administration well now she wants to add
north las vegas mayor to that resume i
spoke with her this week about her
campaign
why run for mayor
running for mayor gets me closer to the
people
i believe we've done a lot of good
things in carson city at the state level
to enhance people's lives
to make things better
but once the governor signs those bills
it's almost impossible to know if all of
them have been implemented or even if
they've been
implemented correctly so what this does
is it gives me a chance to take the
knowledge the experience and the
relationships that i have at the state
senate and bring them a lot closer to
the people and make sure that i'm doing
the right thing that makes people's
lives comfortable having that positive
impact we've got to diversify our
economy you know our economy is such
that when las vegas catches a cold north
las vegas gets pneumonia because we
don't have all of the beautiful trinkets
that they do at the uh down on the strip
and so i want to diversify our economy i
have a doctorate in business
administration and my uh assuming my
dissertation has been downloaded almost
a thousand times on every continent in
the world
in europe alone it's close to 200 times
and i talk about sustainable development
and talk about renewable energy that was
what my research was on and so i want to
look at renewable energy i also want to
look at healthcare
we don't really have a good healthcare
delivery system in north las vegas and
so one of the things that i want to do
is develop a medical corridor
also looking at veterans i am a veteran
and i know that even though veteran
status is usually
taken care of at the federal level i
believe that as mayor of north las vegas
i can bring it a lot closer to the
veterans and we can we can make sure
that the services that are afforded to
veterans make sure that they are the
very best we owe veterans nothing less
what policies would you bring to
actually turn it into action at city
hall
so number one i've chaired commerce and
labor for the last four years
before that i was three and a half years
chair of health and human services and
so all the committee work that i've done
also chaired the subcommittee on energy
in 2019.
all those things that i've done already
give me an opportunity to say this is
the policy level at the state this is
the policy of the state level now how do
we how do we make sure that this is
working at the the uh local level
so one of the policies that i would do
is to make sure that everything that we
build has got to be leed certified
because you know number one we don't
have a lot of water here and so
sustainability is very important so we i
would want to make sure that we're
looking at all of the permits and the
applications for permits in north las
vegas make sure that they are looking at
sustainability and making sure that
we're preserving the water as much as we
can we have some neighborhoods who have
been left out and left behind there have
been some neighborhoods that have really
been neglected their words not mine
really been neglected and as mayor of
north las vegas i will make sure that
those neglected neighborhoods are
respected neighborhoods and i'm speaking
specifically about what is going on at
windsor windsor park that is one of the
historic neighborhoods in north las
vegas and it it really is in danger of
being pushed aside for something like uh
light industrial i think is what they
call it and these are people who this is
third generation some of them live there
third generation and the only reason
that windsor park was created was
because we were living during a time of
segregation and you're committed to
preserving i'm committed to preserving
it those those neighborhoods that have
been neglected i'm committed to making
those neighborhoods respected
just to correct myself she is in the
state senate not the assembly up in
carson city you can watch our full
interview with pat spearman on
eightnewsnow.com you can also watch our
interviews with the other candidates
from north las vegas mayor robert taylor
and pamela goins-brown we are working
our way through the candidates up there
next on politics now new rules on ghost
guns where nevada stands on its ghost
gun ban and the new rules in the bind
administration that it plans to put in
place
and are water situations getting worse
why lake mead may go even lower than
expected this year
thank you so much now
you're watching politics now
president joe biden says he will
institute new rules cracking down on
ghost guns those are guns made at home
from kits or component parts nevada
passed a ghost gun ban but it was struck
down by a district court for being too
vague the state has appealed that to the
state supreme court meanwhile sheriff
joe lombardo says there hasn't been a
big problem with ghost guns in clark
county los angeles county though says it
does have a big problem 90 percent of
the ghost guns they've confiscated have
actually come from a nevada company they
say called polymer 80. deputy attorney
general lisa monaco says criminals
choose to use ghost guns because they're
untraceable
but make no mistake
they are real
they can shoot to kill
and they do
joining us to talk about the ghost gun
legislation alex limon from our
washington dc bureau alex let's talk
about the details of president biden's
announcement regarding trying to
regulate these ghost guns
hey there well it was really interesting
to watch this announcement you know
president biden in the rose garden with
a with ghost guns it's not something
that you see every day and it was really
playing into the messaging that
president biden and the biden
administration
are trying to convey and really his
overall message
in that announcement was that ghost guns
are real guns they're equally as
dangerous and equally as deadly as a gun
that you would purchase you know already
put together president biden announced
this final rule on ghost guns it does a
few different things but
most importantly what it does is that it
prohibits businesses from manufacturing
ghost gun kits without serial numbers
that will belong to those guns and it
also prohibits gun dealers from selling
the ghost gun kits
without doing proper background checks
like they would have to do if they were
selling a
an already assembled gun
to any purchaser so that's the
president's proposal about dealing with
ghost guns what's the reaction on
capitol hill from republicans
well we've already heard senator ted
cruz leading an effort for example with
a couple of other senators announcing
new legislation to try to push back and
stop the biden administration from
enforcing this new rule on ghost guns
and i want to read you part of the
statement that senator cruz released he
said
we're pushing back we want to stop the
biden administration from issuing the
final rule expanding the definition of
firearms and instituting a national gun
registry so that is how senator cruz is
kind of characterizing the action that
the biden administration um is taking
and that was alex limon from washington
dc we do expect gun groups like the nra
to file lawsuits as soon as the order is
actually put in place
well lake mead is at its lowest point
ever dropping below 100 60 feet for the
first time
this week and now we could also be
getting less water into the lake itself
that's because lake powell is so low the
hydropower dam will soon quit working
federal water managers are considering
holding back half a million acre feet
that would normally be sent downstream
to lake mead the department of interior
or the interior department is asking the
states on the colorado river to weigh in
on their plan before april 22nd
next on politics now learning from las
vegas visits by bite administration
officials next on politics now
union
[Music]
this week in what to watch more visits
from mine administration officials
energy secretary jennifer granholm was
here on friday you can watch our
interview with her right now on eight
newsnow dot com
next week health and human services
secretary javier becerra will be in town
as well he'll be keynoting the
governor's health provider summit
tuesday at the las vegas convention
center the focus is on providing health
equity and care to nevadans we'll also
keep an eye on things that clark county
school district as students get back
from spring break coming up next week as
well as the ongoing issues with security
and so forth go on there
that'll do it for us here on politics
now we have the latest on political news
over at eightnewsnow.com interviews and
everything you could possibly want
political right there we'll back with
you next week take care
[Music]